each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so now it is my pleasure to introduce
our keynote speaker for this morning
Joseph Khalidi he is a distinguished
engineer at Microsoft and working in the
azure group prior to that he had a
distinguished career at Sun Microsystems
where he was one of the architects of
the solaris operating system and the sun
cluster solaris is an old favorite
operating system of mine and probably
many of you used it as well so it's
really it's really fantastic that we
have him here for this this event yosef
so good morning everybody in the room
and online my name is Yusef collodion
can you guys hear me good good thank you
um my I have an hour or so this morning
my intention is to discuss with you some
of this cloud stuff we're also active in
nowadays I want to start will give you a
bit of background of what I have been
working on in this space and then if you
will segue and what there are some of
the issues we see in this space and how
we be solving some of them and at the
very end I'll tell you more about some
opportunities some open perhaps research
issues we can go all address I've been
working with this Azure since the
beginning actually from day minus one
before we even call it a sure and
frankly before the word cloud was
actually in fashion we started it by
building a large scale very large scale
web application hosting a platform a few
world which over time we evolved into
this very large public loud that we all
know today but for today's presentation
I want to follow a format similar one
behind me here which is talk a bit about
the promise of cloud computing in the
value proposition exactly like once like
this i will not rehash the old stuff but
more interestingly repeat the message
that without large-scale cloud computing
promise cannot be achieved it have very
very large scale scale this number of
machines large networks and so forth I
would hammer the point number of time
with that though given number of
challenges changes of security isolation
performance isolation a number of issues
like that then I want to switch and tell
you concretely how we have been
addressing some of these challenges and
where we have not yet addressed them and
some opportunities to go forward from
that sounds good you can stop me with
questions do at the end I'm fine with
either way so that one marketing slide I
have in my presentation if you are nice
slide and just make sure we are anchored
in the same space here cloud computing
in our definition if you will is about
this delivering of fast illusion sorry a
big illusion of huge computing resources
over the Internet is a service some
speak of it as delivering IT as a
service it's effectively getting your
computer resources network resources as
a server from somewhere else the
location where the cloud is is not very
relevant really to us and it could be at
some public data center like Windows
Azure or amazon for example it could be
some other variation I love basis as
well the point though as you see time
and again you need scale to make all
these value prop we all know about
actually come come through if you want
to talk about the elasticity scale up
etc you need to have a lot of large pool
of resources to which you can get your
resources from I need to have a big big
ecosystem to share the resources between
them as well we see the universe frankly
moving this way the computing universe
if you very much devices that all of us
are carrying and I bet you each one of
us here at these two devices of this
nature may be a smart phone and laptop
many more tablets what have you and we
all know that the stuff we carry
nowadays is only as good as what you get
from somewhere else we've seen this in
the business we see in the computing
industry at large more and more smart
devices everywhere requiring very highly
available highly continuously
available services up in the cloud
somewhere else and a device space as you
know could be devices you and I carry
all the time a phone a laptop whatever
it could be almost anything with an IP
address these buildings maybe this is a
bit older or building here but newer
buildings if you are typically have
stuff they have temperature sensors they
have air conditioning equipment it data
is being generated like crazy from all
over the place but these systems are not
really autonomous if you will they
require sup in the back which is where
the cloud comes in so all our energy to
be honest has been making this slide if
you are real and the cloud stuff we're
talking about this morning is about the
left hand side of this slide let's go
architecture for a second in our mind if
you have a large scale cloud system you
have to follow the those six
architecture tenants behind me if you
are and I claim the same applies whether
you have to build something like Windows
Azure or you building something like
Amazon ec2 and s3 all of them have very
similar characteristics architectural
espeak and there are the first one is of
course virtualization we all have
hardware compute nodes servers in these
systems need to be able to slice and
dice them for a couple of reasons one
reason is first resource allocation of
course yeah there are physical box and
you may need to slice them in smaller
pieces and different dimensions between
memory and CPU and bandwidth depending
on a problem at hand so that's one
reason why you need service
virtualization the other reason of
course is for security River you need
some trusted component in every physical
server which you will do isolation of
those elements both within the server
and in the network as well you can do
isolate some other ways perhaps in
hardware we very much believe the way
you do network isolation is in the
machines and cells which leads me to my
second point you have to also virtualize
the network since one thing you have all
these virtualized
using elements all over the globe all
over the network if you are but they
have to talk to each other and as you
probably know classical networking where
you actually go and buy a switch and
wire it and do the classic of things set
up a VLAN what have you are very nice
static systems and he were talking about
dynamic systems really she says where an
application demands different topologies
rather frequently so you have to have
also a virtualized network and by the
way as I move on I'll then go back to
the slide that tell you how actually
implemented every box here so for now
bear with me think of it as it that
there is a tenant was a requirement if
you're another one is a with love
computer will talk about so-called
scale-out computing we're talking about
horizontal scaling not vertical scaling
don't get me wrong way I think any given
point of time the you cloud provider
will buy machines whatever good cost
performance in the market nowadays
number of course etc but ultimately you
want more scale you'll get more of them
not bigger than fuel so what horizontal
scaling and typically the unit is some
virtual machine size of some sort some
combination of memory CPU power sub
network bandwidth etc which has
implications of course on the apps on
the services that we all right in this
environment okay do not a small thing I
have in the slide here which is
optimizing for me time to recovery it's
really key guys and this is true more
and more if you are right very highly
available services here in these systems
expect figures in these systems you have
a sea of machines physical virtual we're
talking really many of them and you
don't have humans watching every box to
make sure it's up and running and it's
tightly managed and subtle mainframe
these are lots of machines ooh failures
happen expect them expect them in the
hardware expected in a network expected
in a software and the key design point
is to optimize for fast recovery don't
have demise for me time to failure
don't optimize your application to spend
a lot of time initializing and make sure
everything is nice and clean hit the
ground very quickly because you may have
to do it again again all the ideas but
we have to remind ourselves with them
when we build these systems it follows
therefore every machine and these
systems have to be viewed ultimately as
a cash there's no golden machine
anywhere nany's any of these machine
systems that is an any given point of
time any of them can go up in flames
which means the state has to be
externalized the state of your
application the state of the system has
to be able to live in the network up
large you know that means replication
etc but the point is do not assume that
any machine can be kept up forever or
maintained especially if you are
everything is a cache and if you believe
the story the only way you can actually
make it work is throughout the mission
just imagine having tens hundreds of
thousands of servers can you imagine
having humans running around and
patching the OS but Co finding the
network or configuring the application
of course not so you have to have
automation and how do you do automation
the number of schemes I'll touch once on
them in a second unless Lee as we all
know in this room i'm sure online
writing distribute systems is very
difficult most programmers frankly have
difficulty with multi freddie tell them
go to replication distribute systems
handle meet them to recovery and the
like life becomes very very complex so
you want a platform to have much of the
plumbing done for them you want a
platform to have a set of rich services
duplicate file systems cashing services
queuing stuff that we all need to write
applications hopefully done done one
time done by somebody else debugged
scaled and so forth so that most
developers most programmers should worry
about their problem not about computer
science problems of
difficult nature when we started windows
azure by the way these were the tenants
we start this from and we can debate
more points up and down but by and large
you need to have this in the mix to have
a successful cloud system okay I
mentions already I'm gonna say it number
of times to make the storage elder
however you get the value proposition
and to get the determine vestment or
investing in this large in these systems
in each scale why do you need scale
remember the value proposition guess you
can have an application I want more more
capacity you asked for it you don't want
the capacity give it back to the pool
you business spikes etc you know the
story all this implies a large number of
machines but for a cloud provider to
make money in this place they have to
effectively act like an insurance
company I'm attack II don't I'm not an
actuary so maybe I'll bit off a bit my
analogy but you need a large pool of
resources that you share effectively
between a bunch of people you may want
at the moment a thousand VMs she may
want to only attend this moment and vice
versa I can assure you I have slides but
not for this presentation from a
business size to show you businesses
have very much a seasonal nature of
things during the day even of course
weekly monthly and a certain time during
the year in many other sciences as well
their peaks and valleys of design of
oviedo capacity so the way your clock
provider I can handle this thing is by
having a large scale system
over-provisioning a bit if you will and
hopefully statistically speaking have
enough capacity for everybody but that
means at any point of time company X a
company why homie be competitors maybe
sharing the same cloud it could be
shaving the same physical machine
therefore you have to isolate them and
therefore the discussion we had earlier
about virtualization both of the network
in a servant up
to be able another point here to get all
this scale here the illusion has to be
by and large debt of a uniform system
now don't take me literally it's not
exactly uniform yet the precise of VMs
and so forth but Hezbollah has been
larger another uniform here if your app
requires and make this up 16 gigabyte
memory and this kind of GPU and this
wire and this understand that you know
it may not fit in a public load you may
want to buy a bunch of machines and do
your own special thing you'll find out
in this system they are fairly uniform
we have some specializations special
clusters fast and machines and so forth
but by and large you need to end up with
a model that's that of a horizontal
scaling what the units are a small set
of fixed sizes if you want to customize
quite a bit you'll find out large-scale
clouds are not really appropriate for
customization if when i use utility
computing models if you are where you go
and ask for resources and you find a
bunch of them you'll be forced to fit a
certain model so uniformity is important
lastly as my less potent a point in a
slide shows our essays at least
virtualization is necessary for the
reason we discuss already but specially
not sufficient there is more than just
virtualizing the competition that I'll
explain a bit more in a second as well
okay so remember there's a key point
here is this we all believe in the value
proposition the cloud elasticity becomes
the scale increase utilization what have
you the only way distraction really make
sense if you have scale if the cloud
provider standing behind this value
proposition has scaled to meet the
demand but with the scale we have to
share I cannot dedicate resources to one
of you forever of a long time we have to
share them with sharing you have to do
isolation etc
okay so let's talk about some of the
challenges now and this is why I'll say
virtualization alone is not enough and
I'm touching on 480 as there are more
challenges there's not enough time to
discuss everything here one is what does
it mean for an application to be
cloud-ready what is me to target an
application either to develop it or to
port it or to move it somehow two
o'clock you found out and you find out
easily that a forklift approach
typically does not work yes I can take a
piece of code but in a vm right then a
cloud that's nice and dandy but you want
to make it scale out you're going to
make it highly available you want to
make really make use of the list system
the cloud you find yet do extra work in
there and if you happen to be looking at
something like an enterprise application
with some dependencies on data and so
forth you mean why have you may find out
that you have to keep part of it still
on premises or somewhere else for
lateral reasons so one area i'll touch
on is what does it take to target an
application to the cloud how do you
write these apps what service do you
need to write them and so forth another
area of course is security and I know
security is in generally important
umbrella it's actually doubly so here
because all the sharing points I made
earlier again you and your competitor if
your two companies or two groups could
be running on the same infrastructure
not only do you have to trust your
physical physical security of your
provider and so forth but you have to
have assurances that you know the right
isolation is being done isolation for
you know data privacy even performance
isolation between the different pieces
as well the security is a big deal the
third one so follows in a sense which is
um for two reasons one is a the third
one is about compliance really what are
the rules that govern the operator of
the system and how do you know that the
operator is following there who has
access to your data all the operators it
says
or the management and so forth and in a
different sense and this is more true
for fuel enterprise applications there
are typically regulations there are
typically requirements out there to
prove that you as an operator as a cloud
provider are following the rules so the
compliance pace is also important lastly
with the cloud stuff you are basically
outsourcing the infrastructure managing
it and good also responsibility for
running the system to somebody else and
am using this determine outsourcing very
loosely here guys the cloud is highly
automate and so forth but nonetheless
you need some guarantee from the cloud
provider on what is the service level
expected of student services what are
the performance to guarantee is how many
operations will succeed what's a
percentage of system being up and down
and so forth so you have to be as a
provider able to provide these SLA s and
it's a consumer you have to demand them
and know what you're getting as well ok
I will go through them in a bit more
details but i want to know there are
many other challenges I'm not touching
on today for example actually building
and managing these very large-scale
systems is a big challenge I i believe
we and few others have been tackling it
very well there are a bunch of business
model discussions etc not for today
enough for me at least but those for abs
i mentioned earlier i spend more time on
them right now they're actually really
issues that we are working through and
they're more fun in the same vein if you
are that's not what the first one
targeting apps with our cloud if you are
first i have to admit there's some very
easy cases you know if you have a simple
website static content let's make it
very simple maybe a simple database you
can lift it almost as this and drop it
in a cloud people do this all the time
okay and you see that now platform it's
becoming very easy to
that kind of stuff no me wrong that's a
good amount of computing power in there
it helps with the scale great however in
many cases this forklift approach does
not work you can't just take the app and
run it in the cloud for a number of
reasons to be honest note i've been
using the word app loosely here and real
life applications are very complex
they're actually a graph of things that
depend on each other which pieces can
actually be moved which basically I'll
be moved and supports some of the issue
to consider are on this list here
briefly what is the application state
does the application for example assume
that the state has to always be local
and the golden copy is local you can do
that in a cloud you have to put it
somewhere else you have to find a way to
make it highly available in a storage
system for example somewhere else or
rewrite the application how does your
application scale do you expect to call
your favorite IT person and say order an
extra CPU and more memory for your
application or does it is actually
horizontally scalable application and by
you guys are be very simplistic in my
description here real life is more
complex yet to partition the data and
supports a bunch of aspects to it what
are dependencies of your application is
the standalone system like a simple
website where you just bring it up and
maybe it has a small database in the
back or is a complex graph we depend
this is in local systems or maybe on
some legacy systems maybe on some
storage system we have here and there
and so forth can you give in know a
dependency of your application you'd be
surprised some more enterprise
applications that graph is very very
complex is even hard to find what to cut
the lines along the along those lines
what are the connectivity needs with
application sometimes you have two
components that you want to move into
the cloud together which is great in
some case you have to keep one somewhere
here locally perhaps more remotely is a
protocol chatty between them physics is
physics
so you can't just put them in here and
there and say it's going to work you
have to think of do I have to the
architecture protocol and so forth and
as I alluded to earlier hardware needs
here if your app your space assume
something very special you may not find
it in a very large scale system I mean I
love some of the special hardware one
can use to accelerate certain
application sets but you won't find
these at scale until they become really
more of a commodity play if you were so
can you application be modified or can't
live with off-the-shelf say ethernet
instead of server net or infiniband or
whatever technology your windows this
week lastly as I mentioned earlier the
system system are really hard and anyway
you cut this thing you end up doing some
distribute system programming in the
cloud so the trick is to use canned
services as much as possible for that
let's talk about security for a second I
mean I butter after I finish this
section I'm going to stop then tell you
really how we address each one of these
as well for security as I mentioned
earlier sharing is 0 key point here you
end up sharing resources from different
applications different acute ovals data
has to be stored in sure systems so you
have to isolate them you have to figure
out how to get to these resources so an
identity system and access management
system is needed and enough policy
controls to control how you get to those
resources and of course all the stuff
you really have to demand it to be
independently verified he should
understand us out there by the way I
mean there's some ff8 soup here y is 0
and ssae and what have you but this
serve a useful function there are where
the third party can go and make sure
that yes that cloud provider has been
audited and de followed the rules on the
like for service level guarantees
generally speaking default two
categories availability SLA s and
performance as a days
and typically for something like an
ability SLA it's a ratio of how many
operations of all the total possible
operations they were that that are
guaranteed to succeed so there's always
a possibility of failures case you know
it's a network and there and so forth
and you find things like ninety-nine
point nine five percent of the time
operations will succeed with this power
of line this is also language in there
these can be hard to provide but you'd
ask for them and again the provider has
to provide them what's even harder to
provide especially in a highly share
system our performance isolation and
performance SLA is actually and you find
that that we don't actually offer many
of those in general in industry which is
one of the challenges we have going
forward who performs SLA is some of you
in the room may be interested in this
you know you may require that these two
entities talk to each other with low
latency we want to be to co-locate etc
and that's really not easy at the moment
in a highly sure system will talk more
about this in a second what you find
that many in industry provide nowadays
are basically performance SLA is an hour
so a point not to Matt not to end to end
but only the point basis this virtual
machine you would have so much capacity
to hit the network it's adapter great
but nobody will give you an SLA before
man end-to-end within the network for
example at the moment or a lady see
guarantee etc we'll talk more about two
at the end about this okay so enough of
the architecture and some of the
high-level stuff last big concrete now
what I did to recap is talk briefly
about the cloud you know the value prop
what have you told you some of the
challenges we see in the cloud stemming
from the fact that high sharing in high
school a scale system is needed I'll
spend few slides to just very few here
tell you how what Windows Azure looks
like and then very importantly map these
challenges to how we actually solve them
are solving them in Windows Azure okay
some pictures think of Windows Azure as
an operating system in the cloud it's a
very highly scalable system runs
globally gives you a bunch of services
I'll give you some list of those in a
second allows you to program your
favorite programming language your
favorite programming tool and the whole
idea is that by having enough on that
platform in terms of services and
admitted to manage your applications to
make your life easier it's in a nutshell
gets okay I think many in the room have
been programming the system so i will
not spend much time to explain the
basics of it a key to it though is and
this follows on from the earlier slides
giving a scale you we have to automate
so we behind the cover everything in the
system actually is highly automated
behind the cover we structure the system
through these separate units of
computations these are very large scale
clusters each of which is controlled by
a smaller cluster of so-called fabric
controller and fabric controller is
basically the brain of windows azure and
the whole main loop if you want for
managing windows azure is that you
ultimately submit to the system a big
description of your application it's a
fancy XML graph by the way you do it by
hand or through when the tooling would
give it to you that XML file is
basically ends up being consumed by our
system it describes logically what the
application needs in terms of a network
topology we take this network topology
we have all the physical topologies in
the system how we met them basic oh the
fabric controller does is takes a
logical description from you looks as
the physical inventory it has this
appropriate mapping provisions the
systems all the way from Virginia
machines OS etc very importantly setting
up all the virtualization boundaries
within the actual servers and very
importantly
in the network as well from there on who
we do basic monitoring of the
application to maintain the status quo
to maintain the logical model that we
got from the user if something goes
wrong there are basic health model
activity that we do to restart during
which we replumb all the plumbing to
make sure it's transparent as possible
you get an event of course and
ultimately there are cases where
automation does not work you have to do
something about it and way
oversimplifying but the key point here
is that everything I told you is
automated we don't have people just
watching monitors for every possible
deployment coming in and out and so
forth we will never scale like this a
few more point here all the services
that we expose in the system I see a
slide in a second are available
following the basic architecture I told
you earlier as a bunch of open REST API
it's is everything in the system from
the way you submit to deploy application
to monitor them to access the resources
like storage are through restful api is
yes we are programming languages help
and so forth but this is really a web
platform here you can hit the
application from within the cloud from
some third-party cloud and on-premises
from your local device whatever the case
may be globally we are a we are in eight
locations actually a new slide we just
added two locations few weeks ago it's
actually a major asset by the way and
that we are North America Western Europe
and Asia as well that choice of location
is a policy that you decide both for
computation and for storage you can mix
and match as a secret these are
large-scale data centers they are
globally interconnected through our
global network and also on the slide
behind me if you notice there's also an
optional CDN network a content
distribution network as well that you
could use for applications it's optional
so remember the slide I'm going to just
for each box I'm going to tell you what
we actually have done in Windows Azure
so for virtualization every physical box
has a hypervisor it's built in hyper-v
which is a commercial hypervisor we have
is responsible for dividing every server
into a bunch of VMs one vm is trusted
runs our software in it the rest are
guest VMS that are untrusted then
whatever payload comes from the user the
payload could be a simple high level
piece of code like a web payload if you
were all the way to a full vm now we
have different models in that in that
trusted partition if you are is where we
do our for a second box now our network
virtualization at the edge when I say
the edge think of the network itself and
all the trusted partitions in the system
that's our edge that's when we enforce
the network isolation boundaries between
the various vm graphs in the system so
you may have an application you may have
an application you here we have an
application they're all laid over the
same physical infrastructure those
logical graphs with their isolation are
enforced by the network overlay Network
this again yeah we do more network
virtualization by the way between on
premises in the cloud maybe later on I
mention it but again the key point here
is that effectively is an overlay
Network for scale out as I mentioned
everything is based on the vm boundaries
we have a fixed set of vm sizes they may
change over time but the point is it's a
scale-out horizontal scale model
everything in the system everything
optimizes me time to recovery we expect
your apps to britain that way we have
written our infrastructure that way our
hardware model is like they everything
is life that way and it takes a way of
you actually takes time for people to
think this way guys but everything is
optimized for me time to recovery even
the way we operate the system and what
we have to intervene to do a fixed
problem on the like keeping the live
site up is number one priority
optimizing amitabh recovery is number
one priority then you can go on maybe
figure it out if you have to and support
for caching effort viewing the note is a
cache that to basic mechanisms here one
is we do have a network drive
effectively and externalize durable
network drives so if you have to write
you through classical application of the
Shelf like writing your local filesystem
you're actually writing a remote for you
okay this is key the remote volume it in
turn goes to our storage system which is
highly replicated and so forth but the
rice are durable anything else you have
on a machine which you have access to
local logical drives are so forth out of
cash yeah I'm saying so you can cash as
much as look as you want to we will try
very very hard to keep the cash for you
as long as you're running but ultimately
physics and come in it can crash you
have to be able to go to moti of course
if you happen to be yourself
implementing a highly durable storage
system some people do you effectively
using these local drives as you look a
replica battle and depending on the fact
you have other replicas in the system to
get your durability okay for automation
I already mentioned earlier this system
is model driven so all the provisioning
actions all the actions to recover
restart application and so forth go back
to the logical model that we get from
the application developer or the
two-legged they provide so although to
mission I mentioned earlier comes in
from that logical model and the model by
the way described the topology of the
application basic resource requirements
and also scalability aspects and you can
change them on the fly we change the
number number of machines
behind the number lastly then i'll show
you next live in this one is why we
doing this one we have a very rich set
of services guess I mean most of my
thought was are the plumbing that the
platform and so forth but frankly going
forward much of the investment really is
and all these services the old vision
are then is very simple I want you to be
able to fire up your favorite
programming tool either microsoft visual
studio eclipse or what have you right as
few lines of code for your application
and otherwise compose everything out of
services in the cloud you can use my
services you can use third-party service
I don't care but the point is we need to
live up level level of abstraction here
gas because as I mentioned most of us
don't have time or even the ability at
times to do very complex distribution
systems okay so I'll go quickly through
I told you how we met architecture
principles to what we are built for each
one I'll tell you what to actually have
in there and you see with more details
in their platform now for application
developer development this lie behind me
is what the industry likes to this week
okay I'm not a big fan of it but it's
how we speak of it now it is we have
so-called infrastructure a service which
is in indices speak is you get a bunch
of VMs do it way you want to so called
plasma with a service where you have a
lot of services in that in the plat for
all these services you can actually call
into and you get automation and
management of your operating system
stack and so forth and so a code says is
software service typically the end
product what we fit in the spectrum is
Windows Azure design point is very much
in this part you can build your app to
use both concepts as a matter of fact
you mix and match them in the same
application between applications you may
have some legacy code you want to bring
in a vm go for it you may wanna write
new code or port new code to use full
full abilities with let them go for it
this is what the plasma is about is make
it easy for you to write it up
or port your application to the clock
around this part you end up doing things
like you can go build your own systems
on premises you can use Microsoft
technologies you can use them so other
third-party by and large though you find
your scale point to be much much smaller
here you get all the control you want to
you want a connection to a fibre channel
array go for it you want to talk to you
a mean prim legacy system go for it here
so here you can customize you want
infiniband with the latest hardware go
for it here you'll find us moreover the
scale points i mentioned earlier and
uniformity points i mentioned earlier
and lastly what most people end up with
this platform doing is produce these
things the finished services if you want
the thing we consume from our phones
from our laptops from our tablets so you
have the plumbing you're a bunch of
services either very basic vm running or
a bunch of other hire services are on
that that produce these high-level cloud
services how we all know about the
decider spectrum of course yeah virtual
utilization on premises and physical
systems are so forth so our emphasis has
always been make it easier to get absol
a cloud and to do that we have you have
to have to Li you need to have support
for programming languages now just to be
very clear guess you want to write
something in assembly language on this
platform you can we have one big
customers there Nick good business
reporting cobalt programs this platform
okay I'm not saying you should do that
but my point is you can bring your
favorite programming language to this
platform having said that we make it
easier with a number of SDKs development
tools toolkits libraries with all the
stuff you can take off to write this
platform so we have very good support
for dotnet Java PHP no GS we have SDKs
that specific to certain domains mobile
for example for other mobile phone
platforms or your favorite ones etc
programming tools you can use a
Microsoft tool dotnet from the lowest
possible configuration to the high end
ones and of course you can use eclipse
with Java and other languages as well if
you are doing is a and you just told us
go for it and download the SDK use
command lines have fun not an issue the
point is I keep emphasizing here is that
we recognize that people have code that
exists and they are programming tooling
and languages they exist already and you
can bring whatever you want with this
platform now this is the business slide
I guess by design to impress I knew that
this platform has a rich set of optional
services and building blocks for your
application no I'm going to go through
every box here this is every box is an
hour to our talk if you will each box
behind me most of them at least are
large-scale the severe system problems
solved for you this week we examine
behind me the basic story services stack
in there you want to store a petabyte in
Windows Azure go for it you want to have
very large blobs one terabyte each or
temperature by T is your filter by two
ish go for it you want to have very
highly structured rationally relational
database system as a service go for it
we have one of those as well the point
is there's a number of Rick's services
then the platform here virtually
everything behind me exposed to a REST
API or your favorite programming
language you can mix and match and this
is key to make it easier to actually
program for these systems as I keep keep
saying most people have difficulty
programming very large-scale systems so
the more you depend on existing services
the easier the lodge could be again you
don't have to use any of the stuff but I
recommend you do defaults in six
separate categories services help you
with running your application management
of your application lifecycle
basic storage infrastructure that large
petabytes no sequel infrastructure if
you want a sequel database as a service
support for security and isolation
identity federation single sign-on
number of these scenarios integration
particularly if you have code on
premises or code that you have to go to
third parties and so forth like durable
messaging queuing and so forth and
lastly networking both within the cloud
and between you and the cloud especially
if you will live behind a firewall and
you want to have certain policies will
draw any access to it because the
platform is rich because the application
that run on it are actually quite
diverse so you end up basically mixing
and matching what you need now I keep
talking about so writing the application
yes you have to manage the application
to write so it's one thing to write an
app and say hey it's running you have to
actually watch it and see it and so
forth so there's a bunch of tooling here
from the actual web portal which is
quite rich are quite easy to use to the
underlying api's which are dressed api's
for managing applications but I all our
tooling the web portal the third party
tools our in-house tools use the same
api's so if you don't like the portal
fine don't use it use API as if you want
etc and the third parties of their
already using the same API this one
that's a basic strategy we're following
if you won the api's are available
they're open and we will truly empower
the whole thing
there are set of problems that some of
you may face well you have to connect
your assets your applications running in
the cloud to somewhere else you may have
to connect them to a network you have on
premises in your lab behind a firewall
your enterprise dividend a smaii so we
have a number of services they were
actually in that previous slide I've
mentioned earlier that aid in this
function as well yeah and they start
from the lowest level for example think
of VPN on steroids that this is a
service to you you say I want that part
of a service to connect securely to this
asset on premises all the way to
services to help you with did a
synchronization and managing were data
resides in there okay I mean offline we
can group we can discuss the details
here but the more of these as well talk
was security of it discuss how compute
isolation if you are the basic
virtualization every machine is really
key and as I mentioned we have the basic
hypervisor which is trusted and we do
have a root or as the main partition
which is also trusted small locked down
etc and in it we run our software if you
are that's responsible for the network
virtualization the rest are about your
guess VMS and they are not trusted and
you know what that means really we can
effectively run any vm as far as
security is concerned network isolation
goes hand-in-hand and the way it works
is we basically do also packet filtering
at the network edge as defined as at the
root OS and the little food network
packet filtering basically we end up an
overlay network here so your application
thinks it has the whole network it may
even see its own local IP address range
for example but this actually shared
over an 01 infrastructure in there
and as I mentioned the brain of the
system the fabric controller itself it's
actually running with a bunch of
machines in the cloud as well there are
extra measures of isolations for it for
example all communication between it and
any control software it has in the cloud
itself is SSL mutual identification we
have encryption we also have support to
help for example with key management
distributing secrets your application
may have its own secrets by the way so
we make sure that we store them in the
right way distributing the right vm
recycle them and so forth we have much
of this is already documented by the way
security white paper for example etc so
this information is out there in the
public and to give you an example the
basic model we have of authentication
for the base platform Jurgis and for a
sake of time I would skip the slide but
again all the subjects documented
offline the point of trying to impress
in you is that at the foundational level
we have taken care of all the bases and
the movement now is to move up the stack
and add more services over the
foundational basis everything runs in
highly secure physical infrastructure
data centers we sort of take this for
granted that nice picture I showed you
globally but you know each one of those
is actually much data centers that are
physically secure they have their own
physical security aspects and who can go
in there and so forth I can tell you for
myself I and any Microsoft employee here
we can't even go there I have actually I
cannot even touch the machines myself I
can't touch them physically nor even
logically we have also controls in there
as well these are very important because
we can all invest if you will in the
computer science problem isolated
virtualization and where secrets are and
so forth but a breach of other kind
nature can be a big big big problem so
we have to cover the whole spectrum from
the hard problems too perhaps some even
harder problems here so in addition let
me just Pleasure a couple of things here
geo distribution it's important that
your data
is not only is highly available within a
data center that's also available in
case of the small probability of the
center itself being inaccessible so for
example rights now a storage system are
replicated three times within any given
location and it's also a secrecy
replicated geographically to add more
data center as well that's popular
platform as well you can opt out if you
want to but most people don't opt out
for distance there's more of course for
disaster recovery preparation and the
expectation of the application how they
can recover from it as well and again we
have white papers on this stuff as some
details online compliance the following
me sound a bit dry guess hold with me ok
I have only one slide in this but it's
actually very important for a
large-scale cloud system to actually
make it in a marketplace busy slide I
know it has very three esri one message
to be honest out there a bunch of
industry standards and regulations every
country has a bunch of them every in the
industry has a bunch of them all over
the map if you look carefully at them
however you'll find out the lot of
commonalities between them so what we
have done is forget that I will sue for
a second actual standards names and the
like if we look carefully at we will the
framework basically a controls framework
that covers all these kind of
regulations out there what this means in
practice battery is our system has a lot
of logging auditing processes for
touching the system for touching the
hardware etc we basically generalized
what all these compliance regimes
require or we built them in the platform
out of that you end up obtaining we
enter obtaining certification at the
stations as the market dictates okay
that's the only way one can keep the
sanity to be honest guys because
otherwise if you look at all these
regulations out there the big thick
documents of stuff out there there's
actually good at the uses of this stuff
I mean we should all learn from it i
believe on how we even manage your own
software
who can manage it who can update the
software how often do you get us support
this one nft of course is done through
an audit schedule as well so we have to
be audited all of us do all our
processes and the like it's a fun space
case it's not the same as all the
enterprise software weezer run in all at
a piece of software and ship it if you
want somebody else case over the stuff
now we have to develop the software and
actually run it and all is it this one
almost done guys for SLA a bunch of
yesterday's though you'll notice
something behind me these are mostly
availability yesterday's we don't have
performance today is really by and large
some exceptions here with them you'll
find that in our industry at large that
no performance is a late sorry yes we
will tell you that for a certain vm size
you get so much capacity and so forth
which is a performance statement but
there are no end to end at the moment
performance sls in the industry at large
guys typically the answer is if you
really care about I want latency to be
so many microseconds or milli seconds
from here and there frankly the only to
guarantee it is to build your own
hardware or you go to a custom make
something as a holster if you like so we
are very competitive with the industry
here as far as I've ever ETS delays as a
solution general if you want but
performance SLA is we all of us have
some ways to go which leads into my last
slide there are a bunch of challenges
really meaning out there and we actually
would love to collaborate with many of
you on some of those one is to segue
from the last slide is network
performance guarantees effectively end
to end performance guarantees i guess
just think about it we the problem is
you we have to overlay all these
separate graphs on the same physical
infrastructure your graph is one
application you're Greg's not the
application I want to guarantee you x
percent of the network and y % of the
network how do I do that okay then
literature has a bunch of ideas we have
ideas and the like
this is important so we can offer
depreciate services through customers
and a way to guarantee the performance
perhaps over time forever whatever that
gives me for a given application
personable application so this one A one
one problem space if you were another
one is of course optimas optimizing by
scale computing over data shipping
computation to data probably all the way
around but you know you r do MapReduce
over your large data store in a highly
share system in a secure way the
security aspects here you have to do how
do you say I'm Boxster how do you make
it very very fast if you want doing so
as well now we all know in the teacher
all over the place but please place it
in the same context of describing in
here today which is a highly shared
system and you find out there are
problems with isolation that oops the
only I can do this thing you have to
copy the data here copy competition
there do some stuff on the side but
copying a petabyte is copying a better
by disqus slow so what do you do the
above the first two points are mostly
about mechanisms we are increasingly not
noting that we must employ more
economical models in how we apportion
price and give resources manage the sasa
between customers here again the bunch
of papers on this we actually have a you
system that requires this I personally
find the intersection of economical
models and computing very very
interesting and I'm more importantly
perhaps I also find out I believe that
now we found out we actually need stuff
you know before was nice ideas now
actually sub is really need it lastly
and this should be self-evident that we
do some work at Berkeley a few years ago
as well machine learning can come to a
rescue and many would make too many
things and here we have very large
systems very large systems guys we don't
volunteer the numbers but we're talking
very large system here the number of
events we can generate out of it is is
quite a lot from the actual software
hardware custom events and so forth
so be great to be able to apply machine
learning do things like your prediction
root cause analysis trend analysis or
what have you yes we have also telemetry
and the like that would be great to know
problems before they happen on stuff
like that as well okay guys should stop
talking because I'm sure somebody has
some questions I did I hope so I'm
almost out of time but if you okay
couple questions perhaps guys thank you
so we got start a little bit late so I
think we could push our break back a few
minutes we have some questions hang on
we've got use the microphone so the
people on the web will hear your
question hi this is a special about the
uniform Missa tee of the compute
platform so TC all-wise there's a trend
too many call computers and the question
is whether the assumption that you have
many small computers forming the cloud
will remain valid over time or whether
cloud rather becomes a set of clusters
so a network of Marty computers you
dropped off at the end it all becomes a
set of clusters you're saying yes and
and follow up once we are there then you
want to sing about colocation and you
want to develop vocabulary to express
this so what is your comment sure this
respect to us so there's not like a few
things first we we strive to give a
uniform model and I believe in general
if the entity will start to provide a
uniform model but as you know it is the
physics of acquiring machines and
retiring machines behind the cover we do
have heterogeneous systems this time we
started this project five years ago you
know how this course so you wind up with
liver abstraction to as much as possible
give you a uniform system the forces to
make it not uniform include where they
mentioned earlier the fact that we have
to buy machines and desire machine and
so forth includes desire by some
customers many castles perhaps to have
specialized systems me more memory
faster networks maybe
we use it cetera I do believe you see it
we see a bit more heterogeneity in these
systems you will see some look at me
wrong but you will not see customization
or customizability if you want yeah I'm
saying and be qualitative in my
discussion here so as things like GPUs
become not just cheaper but less
power-hungry and not as hot there's a
pound with them by the way you may see
them more and more in as production
systems for example same with maybe
special networks on the like whether we
expose him as a cluster boundary versus
something else I probably not a
clustered as I mentioned earlier that
the when I mentioned the word cluster
earlier in my presentation I showed you
something behind dougie the cover that's
our unit of allocation and containing
certain boundaries and so forth what
will probably strive to provide you is
with the specialization you want within
a fixed set regardless where the
boundary is as far as we are the same
lady see you know boundary if you like
Cynthia center so you won't be given a
cluster for you this time listed at a
time the time multiplexing that way
would not really work very well for us
now this surface is early to be honest
in the limit if the skin becomes even
even more than what we're taking off
yeah maybe we can give you a whole
cluster for a wife example oh I know
that there are enterprise scenarios
where where people who want to commit
resource allocation for a longer time
for one we want to have more control
over the boundary and those models may
actually happen in this year as well
we'll see suffers view any other
plenty of time
I I have a question regarding the
targeting application to crown that you
mentioned you mention that we need to
consider lots of the question but Azula
when he was that it developed is try to
make people feel that we can use that to
develop many application but it seems
that to me i found your talk that you
need to be very specific or some niche
and not many applications like the
mobile phone can take vintage of this
the question is about targeting abstract
loud then is it a niche application
system or more general yeah if anything
it's actually quite general i mean i
skipped some marking slider can show you
but we have a wide spectrum of customers
from people who do very simple websites
support for mobile phone to tablets have
host computing and heavy-duty enterprise
customers so the answer the question is
I showed us over from bottom up view by
design to tell you that we have support
from multiple models if you were and you
can very importantly mix and match them
as well so you mentioned by name mobile
for example if you want to only thing
out mobile we actually have a
development kit bunch of libraries and
the like to make you just worry about
your mobile problem with a back-end for
your favorite mobile operating system or
you can do it all the way down to take
some legacy code and run in the vm all
there are available so we have verticals
where if you were having a dialogue only
about say windows mobile or iOS or
something we can speak that language
only okay but the biological basically
it can be used for the general it's an
OS okay no but the problem is is that
just about your plumbing you have to
have the other sock on top of it can I
ask another question is recording the
performance yes when we use the dist zoo
as a platform to develop a the so well
yes oh how can we know which the three
so we can achieve a better performance
compared to reuse the umph umph umph the
separate individual server sure so the
question of performers and how do you
know that yeah you know the easiest way
to be honest is to run something and
measure it we we strive to give you a
uniform performance regardless where you
land in our clusters okay that's kind of
important to us spot uniformity model
which we strive to do so by and large
you should get uniform behavior although
I have to admit sometimes you may get
different behavior depending where you
land in the system if you are but the
short answer the best way is actually go
around and measure yourself now we have
monitoring infrastructure support and
this new stuff coming as well to make it
easier to mark your application but
you're in you and the best position do a
comparison between say how do we have on
premises if you will and something in
the cloud but the family up the answer
is one level up if you just want to run
into a simple computation in a machine
you may want to just use your local
machine to be honest if you want a
thousand VMs or 200 or you want to add a
vase of a state application all right
use our storage system and the like
that's what the cloud we get for if you
want a glower presence this o'clock one
o'clock is good for 180 grain between
different pieces yeah I'm saying so
there are some cases where DSC can you
tutor to host a piece of competition in
the cloud that's great but usually with
scale the bigger your application needs
or the more sophisticated the
connectivity needs out or the global
presence you need the more use for the
cloud will be for you
sushil Prasad's from georgia state
regarding a second bullet there in terms
of large-scale data and computing what
do you see forthcoming or what is the
projection in terms of you know
collating co-locating computation and
data may be repressing data distributing
it all those issues well at the end of
the day it's physics to be honest yeah
it's especially we have large data it's
should be should be easier to send
computation to a data versus other way
around okay some oh we all know that if
you want so you know if you have large
datasets shovel them around just to run
in a vm few well separated from the rest
is a very cost prohibitive the tension
here is that if your data set is shared
is part of a shared a pre structure
system I'm saying a big storage system
for example right and you want to be
able to compete close to it how close
can you get while yet still being
isolated from everybody else in the
system it can be get very close to them
in the network maybe this machine talk
of this machine we should be okay can
you run securely on the same server
that's providing your data for example
in a highly sure system to do that you
have to have the appropriate security
model as well and so the spectrum in
there and that spectrum has also
different cost models as well so we can
talk offline if you want a lot about
some of the options in there but it's
the building blocks we serving know what
needs to be done but to put them all
together it's not that easy yet so I
think at this point we should we could
take it offline I said he's going to be
around here I'm not sure how long but I
would be okay and we've got a break now
and i would suggest since its 1007 now
we start up the next session seven
minutes or so late so or say 1040 will
start up again so take a break and
joseph will be right thank you again